[Applaudissements]
la caméra là alors oui bonsoir
quel est votre talent mais non nous
regarder la caméra mon talent c'est que
je suis un dragueur professionnel vous
scène au canada et ce depuis depuis à
peu près 25 ans donc vous avez trente
secondes on va dire pour pour vous
pouvez séduire qu'une personne en trente
secondes c'est ça et bah je me fais fort
de réussir ce qu'elle tombe dans vos
bras exactement
donc vous voulez essayer avec le avec
sophie edelstein je vais je veux te faut
voir gloire non et que vous voulez à
l'esprit
même si j'avais la chance d'être avec
toi
ouais je prêche sonnerie google parce
que je trouve en toi puisque genre quand
je regarde tes yeux est ton regard de
braise
ace combat amateur se transforme en
merguez
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
et un petit accent landais me rend
complètement fromage voila j'aimerais je
sais bien qu'il n'y en a pas dans ton
pays mais j'aimerais un chameau pour
pouvoir surfer sauter sur les dunes de
ton corps ou une chèvre pour que tu
puisses non pas une chèvre
je sais qu'il ya deux choses que j'aime
c'est la rose et toi la rose que ça dure
15 jours et toi parce que c'est pour
toujours
cg mer
[Applaudissements]
il a un incroyable talent en douceur
chômage de masse qui s'y passe
gérontophile banon